we were really concerned that someone
would take a picture
it would get out somehow but we managed
to keep it a secret which was pretty
phenomenal
that's patrick dempsey dishing on his
surprise return to grey's anatomy
on wednesday the actor appeared on the
ellen degeneres show and
opened up about how he and his former
co-star ellen pompeo
hoped to spark a little joy this year
with the unexpected return
of derek shepherd you know meredith
grey's late hubby
the impact the response has been
incredibly overwhelming and very moving
it was nice to be able to have it work
out this way he explained that the whole
thing came to be
after a get-together with ellen over the
summer where they brainstormed ways to
encourage people to wear a mask
you know we hadn't spoken in quite some
times who were playing catchments
because what do you think about coming
back onto the show
here's our idea of what we want to do
for season 17 and i was like what a
great opportunity for people and how
great it would be for the fans really to
see everybody reunited in this sort of
bizarre way the 54 year old actor
credits the series writers and its
showrunner krista vernoff
with coming up with the whole concept of
derek visiting meredith during her covet
dream thing
and he said that keeping his cameo a
secret was
top priority nobody knew about it other
than um
abc of course some people at abc uh
krista
and then alan and myself and that was it
and then we started talking to the
directors which would be debbie allen
who's amazing and kevin
kidd who is one of the directors that i
worked with and that was it
and no one knew until i showed up on set
that day
well eti caught up with kevin mckidd who
directed the big episode and also plays
dr owen hunt
following patrick's big return and he
admitted that everyone was pretty
paranoid while shooting that
beach scene and at one point we saw this
boat out on the horizon
and it stayed there for a bit too long
and they were like that's a paparazzi
boat that's a paparazzi boat
but luckily it wasn't a paparazzi bro
but we really thought it was so there
was a lot of paranoia
yeah keeping this thing secret um yeah
cause you are it was stressful
you're on a beach i mean somebody could
see you
yeah we had to walk down that whole
beach so nobody was allowed on it it was
it was a whole production it was like
like a military operation and even
though it was
a little stressful he said it was great
having patrick back
it was this really nostalgic warm
feeling it felt very sort of cathartic
and healing
and and we all get to reminisce about
all those years that we've
worked together so it was really truly
lovely we had just a great catch up
about life and about
where our lives are and you know and
just it
just again it just felt really it felt
like
seeing an old friend from from a long
time ago that i hadn't seen in a while
it was just awesome